Routh's with us in Boston hi Ruth how
are you okay I guess done what's up I'm
trying to get out of my in-laws house we
just want Harold February and it's
really hard to leave and get out of here
I just I don't know what to do right now
I'm working a job that's $12 an hour and
my husband is making $75,000 a year and
it feels like really bad and we tried
everything we had for Darrin I had over
22 credit cards and my mother'll are
charging us $700 in length which is more
than we can even afford still and
although my husband hasn't sure so
basically you have $100,000 household
income yeah and you can't figure out how
to move out only because every month
like I'm so basically a fun explain my
soup recipe for making 35 yeah so how
much debt do you have this is its
draining all this cash so it's basically
credit card debt how much very hard that
do you have I want to say like 15,000
and we have student loans and we're
conversing a mortgage
right now we have 11,000 left to pay off
and the other loan is I want to say 5000
left to pay off so sixteen thousand
student loans 15 min cards and how much
on your cars my husband has a leaf for
$171 and the insurance is 171 I'll show
the car there's no other car it's just
there's so many you guys are you guys
are 34 you know I'm 25 months at 20
oh you've gone all the way into 34 year
old stupid okay yeah I know
so we're also paying the UK
and electricity here and like really
hard to get an apartment and
Massachusetts because the bread starts
at $1,200 for a studio and I had a kid
so um it's really stuck in that I tried
to see if I could sell anything I tried
to sell clothes nothing nothing she was
your husband ders were living he's it
was diver he's a one and a bus driver a
bus driver okay yes inside the city of
Boston yes okay all right
and so how far out of Boston do you have
to go before the rent starts dropping
we've tried the ten miles from right now
with of them could be these are two
miles from Quincy and it's still about
the same it's $1,200 for one bedroom so
what about what about 20 miles 30 miles
40 miles
I haven't searched 20 miles I'm sorry I
haven't searched 20 miles
uh-huh I didn't think so okay all right
um well here's a situation number one
the car is absolute insanity it needs to
be sold you're probably going to have to
borrow a little money to sell it and get
rid of it but a $471 car payment when
you're living with your mother-in-law is
what's you know that's in the land of
stupid that doesn't work okay the second
thing is is you got no bargain with your
mother-in-law here 750 bucks plus
utilities and all these other things
you're paying it's not a deal so I deal
you're completely out of control you do
not have any kind of a written budget
and you and your husband are not working
together on your money did I miss
anything uh I also forgot to mention we
have a private loan that also another
thousand a year well here's what I would
do I would sell the car
I put the student loans on hardship
deferral if you have to stop paying the
credit card for the loss stop paying
them for a month ago it's going to
damage your credit but so what move 2030
miles out
get your rental get your house going to
be here too
back and forth and what to work you can
get a $12 job somewhere out there it's
closer to home and let's get you on a
budget and get this thing turned around
get it where you're writing everything
down every month but you're not a victim
you're not a victim here you're not
stuck every bit of this can be fixed
with the income you have hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]